so hello everybody i am here with
matthew miller matt miller he I should
say Matthew because I just told him just
now that I like formal name so Matthew
Miller those of you might not recognize
his face but a lot of you will know him
from his YouTube channel logos made
flesh where he analyzes movies he also
has other kinds of presentations there a
lot of people have been telling me that
I should be discussing with Matthew and
it's very strange because III had also
watched some of his movie interpretation
that I enjoyed them
and I thought yeah someday it'd be nice
to talk to him and then at some point I
realized that I've already had contact
with Matthew several years ago four
years ago I I was I don't even know how
I came onto his blog but I saw he wrote
a a blog post about the Samaritan woman
and he described the relationship
between Christ and the Samaritan woman
as a courting where Christ was courting
the Samaritan woman in the manner in
which we see in the Old Testament a man
finds his wife and and so I and I wrote
him and we had to a few back and forth
in terms of talking about symbolism and
I was really impressed by his symbolic
intuition so I'm very happy to to get a
chance to talk to him we'll talk about
symbolism talking about movies and also
I'm really curious about how he kind of
developed his own symbolic intuition
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so so Matthew maybe you can introduce
yourself a little bit and we'll go from
there yeah well thanks Jonathan I
appreciate you having me on I remember
that when you got on that blog post and
when you started growing and coming I
was like I know that guy we yeah and
then the same thing I've had people get
on my blog on my channel and said you
need to talk to Jonathan page oh is that
right that's right you've got the right
pronunciation thank you and so I kept
saying it to me and and so I finally I
think I contacted you and said let's do
it let's let's get together so oh no you
know I think it was yeah I reached out
to you and you were on board with it so
yeah I've been it's for me it had just
been a question of time like yeah it's
gonna happen it's gonna happen several
people have been telling me you know
that I need to do this and and it was
just like okay as soon as I you know it
was just a question of opportunity and
then when you wrote me I'm like out
there you go there's your opportunity
let's do this yeah so let me read about
yeah tell me a bit about you know
because you you you told me that you're
your corrections
I forget how you brought you working in
a prison right or go to jail yeah local
local jail you are Clark County Jail
here here make goo-goo Washington and
that's how I make my living
it's definitely an interesting place and
I get a you know basically human
psychology to see how people operate and
and in a different environment that most
people aren't aren't used to so yeah
that's what I thought you must have
quite an insight into the into the human
mind and the human passions and you know
like that you you you get quite a scope
of the type of people that you have to
interact with I imagine yeah people are
people are people are no matter where
they're at and you see people with
basically letting all their I know the
raw side of humanity the place where
people just let it all hang out so we a
lot of people just hide things and you
find out that I've on the outside I've
known it had a good reputation the
outside and they're all struggling with
things on the inside so it's it's it's
thick you know you just get used to the
fact that you know there's kind of two
sides to people oftentimes so I was
concerning when I first started but it's
become second nature now I mean I I know
it pretty well so yeah so so tell me a
little bit about your channel I mean
I've I've watched several of your video
sometimes I'm watching without even
knowing that it was you you know at the
beginning I'd watch several ones and
then when I started to notice your
channel then I thought oh I've seen this
video before I watched you before and
and so tell me a little bit about how
you stumbled on to your way of seeing
patterns because I noticed that you have
a you have a good insight into patterns
and storytelling and and you also seem
to have a good grasp of typology in
terms of the Bible and everything tell
me a little bit about how you came onto
that yeah I went to I guess became a
Christian kind of like yourself you know
I was an evangelical Christian still am
an evangelical Christian I go to a
Protestant church I became a Christian
about the age of thirteen pretty radical
conversion love God and everything like
that and read my Bible pretty often and
so I ended up going to Bible College
when I was after high school and it was
a local Bible College called Moldova
Bible College and I don't know they I
had a class called inductive Bible study
with a guy named red Lubeck professor
named ray Lubeck and we studied Jonah
for like a I don't know whole semester
we tore apart the four chapters of Jonah
yeah and Ray had a pretty interesting
take on Jonah I didn't like the class at
the time cuz I thought it was overkill I
thought man that Bible isn't this deep I
just thought it's just it's more or less
surface you know take it as it is and he
showed me that in fact there was
something more there and I think about a
year later after I had that class maybe
a couple years later I was reading the
Gospel of John I came across the passage
in my personal actually I was teaching
the gospel John to my youth group my to
my kids we're going chapter by chapter
just bringing out some things talking
about things but we were doing in Sunday
school one chapter a week and in my
personal devotions I was reading first
John at the time and it just so happened
that coinciding and those two moments I
read John 3:5 and had a good discussion
about John 3:5 John 3:3 sorry sheez
said you must be born of water I'm sorry
John 3:5 says he must be born of water
in the spirit in ordered into the
kingdom of God but I read that passage
at the same moment I was reading first
John 5:6 which says he came not by water
only he came by water and blood I'm
sorry I'm very I'm just to let everybody
know I'm working out four hours sleep
here but getting those two passage
together I saw that the water was being
used in almost the exact same way and I
thought it was odd that in Protestant
circles those the water is interpreted
quite differently from in those two
passages and one instance water is
thought to be I'm gonna draw a blank on
what it is
water is thought to be something other
than the spirit in John 3:5 and it's
thought to be something else in first
John 5:6 and I thought and they should
be the same thing but we because we're
talking about the same person here using
the same symbolism using the same
shorthand reference for something and in
a long time I came back to so I went
back in a Red John all the way through
looking for clues looking for maybe some
kind of key as to what the water could
mean and I saw that water was everywhere
for the first time I mean I'd read John
like three or four times I knew it
pretty well and all of a sudden the
dividers that I had in my mind between
all these different separate incidences
the you know Jesus changing water to
wine the him healing the man by the Pool
of Bethesda also the flow of blood and
water in John 19:34 all of a sudden
those made sense together not not
separate incidences not as if they were
and we often read the Gospels in our
Protestant circles as as as patently
historical that it's simply what
happened that if I'm reading it simply
what Jesus did last Tuesday and there's
no more significance than that other
than the person picked it out and wanted
you to say there's no shaping there's no
editing there's no artistic element
involved in terms of bringing out the
spiritual meaning of what Jesus was
doing and and that just absolutely
opened my mind so I thought well then
John 3 John 7:37 through 39 Jesus
basically tells us that water and now
those passes water equals the spirit and
yet in other passes
his water is clearly contrasted with the
spirit right yah 1934 you're like is it
the spirit is it not the spirit and how
does that work out in first John 5:6 so
I had all these questions I thought I
had an answer and I thought Lawson so I
just kept on reading and reading and
reading and I picked up lots of books
and so what it I'm sure is because I
mean I have to me the the differences
between water they're pretty simple like
but I but I let me tell you how this is
how I take especially your question
especially how I take and see if that's
the same concluded you came to that
there's a difference between streaming
water or flowing water and and stagnant
water or bitter waters or you know
waters that are just there on the bottom
like the ocean all that all these images
of bitter water in the Old Testament
images of saltwater all of that is very
different from flowing water flowing
water comes from above there's no other
way for flowing water to be flowing it
has to come down and so because of that
it tends to to echo the spiritual
element coming down to earth whereas you
have this water on the ground that's a
salt water which is dead and not living
it has to be transformed by living water
which come from above you know so you
have a lot of these images that you'll
Testament of changing bitter waters into
fresh water all these all these these
changes of fresh and bitter water I mean
you have all these images like we you
know we I talked about we talked about
the idea of the Samaritan woman where
you have a well in the a flowing water
which comes from above so you have like
the water below and the waters above
joining together as an image of sexual
Union but also an image of from Genesis
right this union of the waters above and
the waters below coming together in in
in which can be in a flood if it's
negative but it can also be positive if
it's it's happening at one place like
you know like a masculine feminine
joining together anyways that's how I
would interpret it but what did you what
did you come to it as your conclusion
how do you have you see John 19:34 I'm
in terms of Jesus I'm not I'm not I'm
not a chapters inverse guys so you have
to spell it out this is pierced in his
side and blood and water flow so yeah
that's the culmination I think of the
gospel it's basically the capstone the
the thing that breeds the blossom the
bloom brings it all together how do you
interpret that how have you
I interpreted it as the beginning I
would interpret in in a way as a
beginning in the end you would say and
so water especially if you take the
story of water being turned into wine so
water being turned into wine is really
is the creation process itself right
from yeah from water into this created
thing but then also death with you know
a wine is also death it's like it's a
death turned against itself right it's
fermentation which is which is captured
let's say and so and then there's also
water as there's something that you
drink in terms of refreshing and then
wine as something that is intoxicating
and so it's like the whole gamut of
manifestation you would call it from you
know and so water and wine could be
equivalent to something like bread and
wine as well in the sense of something
which is meant for consumption which is
let's say pure whatever and then blood
which is which is the the the other
extreme the left hand you would say
something like that which is a
fermentation death intoxicant all of
that and blood is that as well like
blood was supposed to yeah that's how I
would see that so it's like the whole
thing it's like the whole world is
coming out of Christ you would say from
the beginning to the end so it is it's
like a new creation coming from Christ's
side yeah absolutely
absolutely that and new creation is the
key right there I think that's that's
the most important idea I think so when
you look at the the first if you start
to read all the passages together so
there's something called the hermeneutic
circle I don't know if you're familiar
with it but I am this is something I've
latched on to and it's kind of been
helpful in terms of how do I read or
understand anything but in
interpretation the hermeneutic circle is
pretty important pretty significant
because it means that we can't know the
meaning of something apart from the
whole of something right we look at the
whole of something and we go back from
the from the vantage point of looking at
the entire completed text to whatever
context and we go back and we look at
each individual part we see how each
individual part connects to the whole
right so it's all apart part to whole
it's there it's pretty significant so if
you read the Gospel of John in its
entirety and you look at all of those
water passages right he's well John's
trying to communicate something to us
it's not like he's just you know brought
this thing
just because but he has a meaning to it
and it is symbolic so what is he how is
he related of that symbolism what does
he want us to get when he gets to that
1934 he says I saw it the one who swears
is true and he knows what he saw I mean
that's John 39 1935 just immediate verse
after I mean he really swears to it and
the only tell you the time he really
gets that that personal with us is at
the very end of John 20 which where he
caps off the end of the gospel when he
says these things have been written that
you may believe and that you may have
life in his name so um what's
interesting is is that you go back and
you follow the patterns you start to see
that the patterns emerge and so in John
the first time it happens is in John 1
and if I go too long on this please go
for it
I'll job you if you're boring so there's
the first time we see water John the
Baptist in John 1 States three times in
rep he repeats himself three times i
baptize in water he says yeah and the
third time he then says but he will
baptize in the Holy Spirit right and we
get that from Mark's Gospel get it from
Luke's Gospel that the fact is that
there's an economy between water baptism
and the Holy Spirit that what John is
doing is somehow different from what
Christ will do and then in John the
second got the the second chapter just
immediately after that Jesus goes to the
wedding and Mary comes to me says they
have no more wine and then Jesus takes
the wine the water sorry and he puts it
in six stone water pot set there for the
Jewish custom of purification and they
draw it out and they take it to
headwater and it becomes wine he says
this stuff is the best stuff then then a
chapter after that John 3:5 r33 when he
talks to Nicodemus at night he says you
must be born again and Nicodemus says
how can I enter my mother's womb a
second time and he says born of water
and spirit you came into the cave of God
then after that and you obviously have
the story the Samaritan woman then after
that you have the story of Jesus human a
man by the Pool of Bethesda anyway all
that to say is there's a pattern that
emerges from those first five chapters
because it's in every single chapter and
what emerges is that there's a
comparison and contrast made between
water and something else which equals
the spirit right well the story the
Samaritan woman you have the story
of Jesus meeting the Samaritan woman and
him she coming down and he says and if
you knew who I was
you would ask me and I would have given
you living water right sir give me this
water so don't only have to come all
with here all the time to to draw water
to drink and the interesting thing about
that is that you say of well water like
you said and you have our and you have
living water which is fresh water
flowing water you have well water which
is lake water it's it's stagnant water
it's it's it's water that's you know
that's stationary from below just water
yeah water from below you can set yeah
yeah absolutely and but there's to the
interesting thing is if you look at the
Samaritan woman's story there's actually
that pattern that conversation that
Jesus has jhanas has shaped it in a very
interesting way I mean maybe he's shaved
it I don't know but had this as how it
goes you have the first half of the
story and then when she says go call
your husband and tell him to come here
she says I have no husband all of a
sudden we have a shift in the content
and in the content of the subject of the
conversation which is now about her
marital status mm-hm and then she shifts
it again saying sir I perceive it you're
a prophet
she says you worship on this mountain we
worship on this mountain which mountain
should we worship on and then Jesus says
it's neither this mountain nor that
mountain but but but the God seeks the
father seeks to it for worshipers to
worship Him in spirit and in truth
that's speaking for is worship because
God is spirit we must worship in the
spirit of truth now if you take those
two halves now look at this real quick
you have that that first half of the
conversation and the second half of the
conversation the first half is well
water contrasted with living water well
water is a well of water is dead it's
it's but but she connects it to the
traditional site of father Jacobs well
she says are you greater than father
Jacob who gave us this well not word
father's important because it comes up
in the second half and Jesus says my
water will well up become a spring of
life welling up to eternal life so yes I
am greater than Father Jacob and his
well the second half she says she says
our fathers get that our fathers
worshiped on this mountain you say we
should work show up on this one which
mountain should we worship on and Jesus
says it's nice
this mountain or that matter but we
should worship in spirit truth living
water is connected with spirit
worshiping in truth whereas the well
water is connected to a traditional
place a traditional place which is given
by the tradition of father jacob these
is this old-time religion yeah is the
mountain worship is the same thing our
fathers gave us mat worship on this
mountain and Jesus is saying it's not by
location but the spirit breaks every
border the spirit goes beyond borders it
is you know not to say that there's
something negative in those things
that's fine but Jesus says as superseded
what has came before his he's come for
and we can see that in in John 2 where
the story is of water and wine it's not
just wine the story doesn't say it's
just wine it calls it water turn wine so
there's a contrast between water which
is given out water which is is is has
you know wine the basically the story
goes in the wine they were drinking and
it gave out and when Jesus makes the
wine he goes to the head waiter and the
head waiter says this is how it always
works people put out the best stuff
first and when everyone is drunk then
they bring out the cheap stuff but you
have saved the best for last best till
now and so you have a contrast between
two different waters you have water
which is impotent powerless and then you
have water which is surpassing and
awesome which is the spirit that's why
we call wine liquor we call it spirits
it's the idea that something
intoxicating has happened so there's
there's water which is given out and
that water is based upon what she was
tradition because he says he took the
six stone water pots set there for the
Jewish custom of purification and he
transformed that he didn't just take the
wine jars the empty wine jars he
specifically took something which was
associated with tradition ritual ritual
cleansing and transformed it into
something which superseded that which
was all-encompassing which was way
better and this thing goes with John's
baptism what is John's baptism in
Chapter one John baptizes in water
baptized in water he says but he will
baptize in the Holy Spirit and what
John's baptism baptism was and it's a
significance important for Christians
and everything like that but if you
think about what John's baptism was it
was a Jewish custom of ritual
purification because if you go to Israel
today and you see all the archaeology is
that everybody was doing ritual baths
all the time even before you entered the
temple you were going into a bath to
wash yourself to purify yourself before
you entered into any holy place yeah so
John took that idea and made it a one
time baptism of repentance in the Jordan
River and so in essence what John was
doing was a ritual form of purification
this is an act of purification but what
Jesus does is he transforms the ritual
and makes it something he superspies
supersedes it or surpasses it all of
those aspects the story of John 5:2 when
Jesus has the healing of the man by the
Pool of Bethesda the man says he comes
to the man and he says do you want to
get well and the man looks to the pool
of water and says hey I do want to get
well but when the water is stirred up
and it doesn't sweat it moves yeah yeah
it's the third active there is a passage
in the King James Bible that tells us
that it was an angel that came down but
it's actually not in the original text
but the idea is the water gets stirred
up and he he says I can't get in because
somebody gets down before me and Jesus
says take up your pallet and walk pick
up your mat and walk and what's
interesting is is that story is there's
a contrast made the man's looks to a
traditional site a ritual site he sees
in this place where all of these laying
people are gathered together to get into
the water when the water stirred up
that's tradition that's ritual and what
Jesus says is hey turn your attention to
me pick up your pallet and walk dan says
superceded or surpassed and what's
interesting is in John 5 that's the
first time that you don't have an active
contrast made between the water the
lower earthly water below with the water
above Jesus has taken the place of that
water that container of water and that's
what we're gonna see the rest the rest
of the gospel John is that Jesus is
infused he has the water inside him
and then we'll see that in John 9 and
John 11 Jesus weeping and the fact that
he spits on the ground in John 9
preserve and then and then when the the
spear thrust happens in in 1934 yeah I
would say in terms of I mean I think I
agree with most of what you said I think
that for sure that the language of that
what the language that I would tend to
want to use is a kind of recreation or
are a filling up let's say because when
we when we use the language of
supersession sometimes it can give the
impression that we're we're how can I
say this that it's completely being left
behind whereas whereas Christ fills up
let's say takes let's say the ritual
Passover fills it up but you overflowing
and makes it into communion takes the
ritual of ritual purification fills it
up into overflowing and so then we still
have a ritual of baptism we still have
communion but that but it's it's a it
becomes this full full becomes full and
and overflowing and also it overflows
also into the you know into the into the
nations right it's not just for the Jews
it becomes this thing that this
Pentecostal thing which kind of flows
out the question I have though is did
you did you ever make the connection in
terms of spirit and water to the very
first passage in Genesis yeah right yeah
use this repetition of the same it's
just over and over the same pattern of
the spirit above the water spirit above
the waters and so Christ connects them
especially at his baptism that's where
you see that actually Christ is the one
who connects the waters with the spirit
because he's down in the waters and him
the spirit comes and lands upon him so
he becomes the connection between heaven
and earth if you get even more deep into
John and I didn't get into this but the
idea when John says I baptized in water
three times and in the next day it says
that he says it again and then he says
but he will baptize the Holy Spirit what
John does in the first chapter of John
into the second chapter of John is he
gives us a series of six to seven days
John says it the next day the next day
the next day and if you if you follow
out those days they end up to be
somewhat comparable to the old to the
first chapter Genesis which is you know
Jesus got the first second third fourth
and what's interesting is in the first
day what does God do he separates the
light from the darkness right he calls
the light day cause the darkness night
knew it was evening the more in the
first day and what's interesting is then
John the one one one two we have that
separation that him was life and that
life was the light of men and the light
shines in the darkness and darkness has
not overcome it and then that's the
first day so there's a comparison made
and then in a little bit later I think
around I can't remember a little bit
later it says and the next day well that
next day falls on the second day and the
second day in Genesis is what happens
God Jesus
I mean God divides the water well you'd
say things remained it's okay that's
right so the it says that he divided the
waters so there was a merman there was
waters they divided the waters the
waters above from the waters below and
what ends up falling on the second day
where John says i baptize with water but
he baptized in the holy spirit and
that's why I connect the Holy Spirit
with water from above yeah the water
that john has with the water from below
yeah that part of that is traditional
earthly you know but but he surpasses
that and is over shouting that and we
see them john edward he's a lamb from
above you were from below i am of this
world you are you you are of this world
I am not of this world
if you know if you look at the old if
you look at the old baptismal fonts
you'll see that they usually were cross
shaped and they had they they often had
a fountain in the middle so they had a
cross shape and that it found so the the
the baptismal font would actually be a a
water below and then it would have a
fountain that would kind of drop back
into the water so you would have this he
would come to the place it's like in 20
because people people always ask him
because the you know the Catholics they
baptize from above they put the water
from above and Protestants tend to
baptize from below even the Orthodox
also we tend to put down from below but
I think that I think that if you look at
the images the early images of baptism
it looks like it's both at the same time
it really looks like you see Christ as
he if you look at the images of the
baptism of Christ you see that he goes
down into the water then you see st.
John also pouring something above him
either either has his hand up there you
see the spirit coming down or he has a
shell or something and he's
water down from above and so I'd really
think that it's it's this joining
together of the both of the both waters
you get a little bit of that in the
Orthodox tradition now sometimes I've
seen it where when someone gets baptized
they'll actually the priest will will
create this this like flow of water
right they'll actually with their hand
they'll make this gesture so that the
water will kind of kind of come back on
top of the person's head as they're kind
of you know going down in under water I
don't know like what how that started
that tradition but I've seen that done
quite a few times by some some priests
anyway
interesting I should I should add to and
I talked about super session or whatever
in the Gospel John I do not believe that
John is saying we should have no
tradition or that tradition is wrong in
some sense because in John 1 he says for
instance he's talking about the law of
Moses he says grace came through Moses
grace came through the law but but grace
and truth came through Jesus Christ so
there's this idea and and it also says
something about basically that what God
is given is he given he gave us grace in
the Old Testament but he's given us
grace upon grace in and in the new so
the fact is is that these things were
not wrong they were not yeah I mean it's
a tradition and ritual are but they only
get you so far that's the thing is and I
think that's what John's point is is
that we have we have these traditions we
have ritual everybody does and
Protestants will deny that they do but
they're just as much tradition oriented
as anyone else and but but the idea is
is that it is a heart transformation
that John is talking about he's talking
about a life transformed by the Spirit
of God in spirit and in truth yeah
somebody is my big question for you I
guess now I will go and get into the
movie stuff a bit later but might be
question is as you start to approach
things that way in terms of interpreting
and Chuck terms have seen the patterns
and seeing the typology between the Old
Testament and New Testament and how it
plays out in in the New Testament so my
big question is how do you that say how
has this been received in your circles
like how do people perceive what you're
doing like how do they interpret how do
they see another interpret well I think
I think right
I grew up in a
kostol I mean that's where I grew up a
tripping of Pentecostal circles which is
very very literal
I mean reads the Scriptures very
literally so that's how I was I was
taught I was and so I think the people
that I know closest have been their eyes
have been open they're like wow that's
really cool I never saw that before
they're interested and I've gotten
pushback from people like I don't get it
I don't understand some people might
just think I'm crazy that's why I look
at you and go and you got to have people
that think you're crazy and that you're
not you're like what are you getting
those ideas from you know because it's
not so obvious to people how you get
from point A to point B or C or D when
you when they don't steps in between so
you know so yes it's been good and yes
it's also led to some confusion on
people who look at me and scratch their
head and go I don't I don't get it so
because I think that and I think
symbolism symbolism to a lot of people
there's a tendency in Protestant circles
particularly that the Bible is
historical so they read the Bible with
this is what happens so like the Gospels
are essentially a diary of Jesus's
activity and it was written as it
occurred almost like no editing nothing
just just that this is what happened and
then we did this and we did this and we
did this so each individual aspect of
what Jesus did is significant in its own
right not so what do you think that this
has been the one the thing that I've
been trying to get people to see mostly
and maybe and maybe I don't finally
pushing your lid further than what you
usually tend to think of is that there
is no such thing I keep telling you
there's no such thing as literal there
is no literal in the sense that there
are plenty of things that happen to
Christ that were not mentioned mm-hmm
within even in the selection process
there's a form of symbolic compression
yeah oh Christ you know what Christ did
all kinds of things you know you put on
his clothes he he he cleaned his
fingernails he did all kinds of things
that everybody does but we don't mention
those things because they're not
meaningful that's right yeah
then to me what I keep telling people
that logos is a logos is a is a is a
form of compression of meaning so you
you have all these details and the very
fact that you choose certain elements
within a narrative
it means that they're already you're in
a form of of meaning making or
participating in meaning not just none
and and and ultimately what I I'm trying
to to get people to accept or understand
is that the pattern that we see in
Scripture that the basic pattern the one
from Genesis that we see all the way
into the gospel is not just a literary
pattern that it's actually the pattern
of reality actually the pattern by which
we engage the world in terms of
phenomenology so the very fact that even
even in our own lives we have to create
synthesis of meaning to create
narratives like we exist in narratives
we live our lives our stories we don't
we don't live our lives as an indefinite
amount of of arbitrary details we rather
compress them into two narrative form
and that compression is the structure of
a reality because there's too many
details there's like an infinite amount
of them right the world if you if you
don't have logos the world scatters into
dust like it'll just keep scattering
until it reaches it reaches dust but but
the Bible and and tradition gives us
this this pattern by which to basically
see the world with yeah absolutely I I
think just to take off what you just
said my my dad was a storyteller so my
dad was he was a pastor for a bit but
then he went on to become a teen suicide
prevention counselor so he'd go to high
schools all over the world the world and
basically do seminars so he's a public
speaker gets up and tells stories that's
what he was he's a gifted storyteller
he'll tell a story anywhere everywhere
he'll and everyone's engaged by the
stories that he tells but me sitting
back and watching him do that
I recognize that a story gets slightly
shaped depending on the context with
which it's being delivered so the point
of the story isn't simply the story
itself it's the meaning or message which
is shaped by the context and so that's
what the Gospel writers are doing
they're telling us a story not just
because it's the story that's important
but it's the meaning or the what we call
this it's in Lebanon in biblical circles
the life setting of a situation of the
people to whom who was given so Mark's
Gospel is different from Luke's Gospel
and John's Gospel not necessarily
because you know geez
is life different all that much but it's
the point that they're trying to get
their audiences to perceive and we see
that in in adaptations of movies if we
just bring in movies for instance we see
adaptations for different settings if
you see a movie made in the 50s and it's
remade there might be some radical
differences between that and it's
significant of those those differences
one an illustration I like to use is the
Last Supper by Leonardo da Vinci and
everybody's on one side of the table we
all see it you know if you got in your
head your mind that there's something
unique about the situation in which that
painting was made it was made in a
refectory like it was made in a dining
hall and this is what don't get they see
it on their wall they put it on their
wall they see it in a magazine they see
it wherever but they're not getting the
context of where that painting was made
and it was made as an extension for I'm
sitting in the table with us right at
the seating arrangement exactly and
that's and and Leonardo knew that and we
all know that that wasn't literally
Jesus having the Last Supper that's not
what it looked like but the meaning that
was it was it was bringing that
application into the people who are now
dining with Jesus and singing and the
point at which we all know the point of
which to leave the painting was made was
one of you will betray me and the
question is every time you've eaten your
supper with Jesus now you're like is it
is it me Lord
well I betray you that question is now
on the minds of everyone eating and with
Jesus so that so the meaning becomes
thus it's the situation the context of
the painting itself becomes the means by
which we interpret the painting but yet
but yet nobody says well that wasn't the
Last Supper you can't say that wasn't
the last it is the last stuff it is less
effort yeah and and that's the thing
about image making - because I most my
main job is being an image maker really
you're making images you are you realize
that you're that you make choices that
you're compressing you're compressing
things into into a frame you have to
bring things together and so you act you
have to do that in a way that is making
it meaningful because good you could
take you could have representative
behind everybody's head and have
everybody from behind you don't see or
you could have represented from a fly's
view looking at you know that just
adjust the the tablecloth of the table
so know you when you could when you
frame a event or you frame something in
an image you have to make it meaningful
you have to participate in its meaning
or else or else it's irrelevant or else
no one cares and it's or you're just
being you know what we have people who
do that today but they're just trying to
be innovative for being in a innovation
thank you know to surprise you but even
if they do that you know it's like you
could create you could create an image
of the Last Supper by which you see
everybody from the bottom and you just
see the bottom of their feet and then
you would see that it's a Last Supper
and and someone would think that they're
being extremely surprising and
subversive and innovative but the only
reason why you even care about that
image because you have the reference of
the actual normal image in your mind and
now you're seeing this as an exception
to that norm so you know it you can't
avoid it you can't get out
and that's the hermeneutic circle right
there is because we all have to have and
this is the problem with the Hermitage
circle is that it's circular meaning
that we we have to have information in
order to interpret right you can't
interpret without that information so
there's things that people miss all the
time because they don't have that
reference you're supposed to have the
reference when you see the image or
watch the movie or whatever and that's
that's partly where I get into the movie
thing is that people don't know the
Bible and then you know that's what
they're doing they're referring to the
Bible so which brings in the reference
that people go I don't see that well of
course you don't see it because you
don't know the reference right exactly
and and yeah you're losing the main
reference that all that all narrative in
the West has been alluding to from you
know from since the last 1500 years or
whatever
yeah it's definitely lost that's why
someone like Camille Paglia who's an
atheist you know transgender lesbian she
says the best thing we can do right now
is teach the Bible to our students
because they're losing the referee
losing the mesh you know the underlying
mesh for Western society and they
basically can't read anymore because
they don't they don't they have nothing
to look at the world through that's
right we're and that's the fragmentation
of our society where everybody has their
own little enclaves of meaning no
there's no grand narrative I mean
that's fine if you want to say there's
no Pantera - but basically you're
destroying society in the process you're
breaking it now yeah so here okay so now
before we do get into the movie stuff
here's the big question this is kind of
the point the question that because I've
met several Protestants who who have
this kind of symbolic intuition and I
and I'm always excited to talk to two
people that have this intuition but I
always have the big my big question is
why are what about liturgy like what
about the rest right what about the
architecture what about the the liturgy
what about the liturgical year what
about all those patterns which are
because there's the the pattern of
reading which is an intellectual
exercise let's say but then there's the
lived pattern you know there's the moral
side which is there of course but
there's also the live communal pattern
which is the making the world look like
this pattern like let's say this
overflowing of the spirit into the world
and the world being shaped by the spirit
and so that's how we see it's a
traditional Christians that's how we see
the fact that our churches have a
certain shape that our time is now
marked by festive feasts how you know
the liturgy becomes the ultimate you
know pattern of participation in the
life of God in terms of of patterning
itself on revelations and bringing all
these patterns together and so how do
you like what's your take on on liturgy
and architecture and art and all that I
think it's like I said I think it's
fantastic I think that is the i think
they they've reached the the peak the
pinnacle of what we're supposed to do I
just might my take on it I guess why am
i I guess I've flirted with becoming
both Catholic and Eastern Orthodox you
know the idea I've been to the
monasteries and things like that and and
and read I guess why am i a Protestant I
guess because I'm I am a Protestant I
haven't like you know swam a Tiber or I
don't know the comparable thing for
becoming easier
the it's it's it's Fanta I think that
being devoted to the Bible and I think
that and I'm not saying that
Eastern Orthodox or Catholics aren't but
innovative American culture is
innovative we want to do everything
differently and I think that's what
we're all doing exactly what you just
said is to take the art and make it take
our lives and somehow be cruciform put
in the shape of the cross for a whole
entire life everything we do to be
shaped and by that narrative by that
story
um I think Protestants go about it a
different way but they are doing that
and I think that's the goal of what
we're doing so they just have a
different liturgy a different way of
going about it so I'm not gonna deny
that we have a liturgy we do we just go
about and it's shaped a little bit
different I don't like and I preached a
message of my church while back and I
actually went down to the local Catholic
Church and I got a crucifix and I
brought it up and I hung it on the wall
for my Pentecostal I fit across the
church and that to them is like an
athame it's almost like an idol you're
putting an idol on the wall and I'm like
not this is the moment of Jesus
coronation this is the moment of you see
a picture of of a queen being crowned
queen or a king being crowned king
there's there's emblems and symbols that
are that are associated with the globe
you know the little you know if you see
you know talk about the crucifix in your
sermon like you kind of this we we
eradicate the cross as not the moment of
Christ's glory we say it's the moment of
his death and it's empty now and
therefore it's empty in the tomb was the
most important thing in the fact that
Christ is resurrected and I'm like
that's not the moment of glory the
moment of his glory is when he was
crucified that's the moment he was
crowned king and that's biblical that's
based upon the Gospel of Mark and the
way the Gospel writers interpreted so
also the cross the the thing about
understanding let's say how Christian
imagery works is that it works in a
pattern as well and so we have the cross
but we also have the honest assets for
example in the Orthodox tradition where
we see the harrowing of hell we have
Christ in glory sitting on his throne at
the Last Judgement we have Christ in the
manger being born and showing you know
showing this this first moment of the
entering into the world and so all these
images they don't exist in a bubble so
it's not like all we have is Christ dead
on the cross we have cried that on the
cross which is speaking to Christ at the
Ascension on his throne you know all
these images are in a pattern together
just like in the just like in the Bible
we don't only have the moment of
Christ's crucifixion we have it in the
pattern of of storytelling but we also
have a pattern of image making in which
all these images are talking to each
other the way that they're talking to
each other and the Bible as well so but
I I understand like I remembered I was
young - I remember that argument saying
it's like why would you show Christ on
the cross
you know just price dead and it's like
yeah that's one image you know we have
all these other images yeah it's so I
don't know what to say about that III
have a met an element blog I have a
series that I did not a series but at
one time shot Theo where I talk about
the Bible being our grand unifying
narrative and that the Bible is
incomplete it tells us the beginning
tells us the middle and tells us the end
but there's a point in in that story
which isn't finished yet and that we
stand in that place improving it's it's
basically directed improv we look to the
past and we look to the future and we'd
if we read the Bible and sense of
because most most the Bible people go to
the Bible to say I need an answer for my
life I need to answer so they they find
a verse or proof text or whatever but
it's not doesn't work that way and I
think that the Eastern Orthodox get this
is the idea that it's a story and we
find ourself in that story and we are
becoming part of that story and in some
sense that's all been worked out by the
history of the church and I think that
simply Protestants are just recreating
it you know 1500 years ago they're there
they're doing the same thing but they're
going back in time to redo it all and
eventually I think that it'll start
looking somewhat the same so go to a
table that'd be great if it did like
you'll be great if it if it starts to so
let's talk about movies so this is I you
know what one of the reason why I do
making movie interpretations and you
said something before is
is that seems to connect the reason why
I'm doing it is that I noticed that
people don't they become blind to the
Bible stories people they don't see them
anymore because it's it's as if either
they they've been soaking in them and
they just see them as things that
happened like you said where they don't
they don't see them as this patterning
or they they've turned away from them
and they and they don't care and so they
they think they're boring and that these
stories are just a bunch of
superstitious nonsense and so the thing
that I thought is if I can show people
the patterns in our other stories right
the movies is a great is easy to do
because we're it's a video medium and
everything I can show people patterns in
our other stories then I can slowly
point them to say oh you think those
patterns are cool let me show you some
let me show you some real storytelling
let me show you some amazing you know
patterning here yeah so you you build
your credit your credibility by saying
we all know that this movie is you you
have no expectations about a movie you
don't have any tradition about a movie a
movie comes on you say it is or it isn't
and and people are fairly open-minded
when it comes to the interpretation of
that and it allows us to have kind of a
halfway meeting point about the idea of
interpretation what interpretation is
hermeneutics and then you can take them
back to the scripture and say if that's
symbolic perhaps something in the Bible
is symbolic as well
uh-huh becomes at that absolutely what
you're saying Sam and I'm curious about
how like I imagine people are writing
you sometimes and in terms of let's say
you feel like the lot of the people that
are watching your videos are mostly kind
of Christians who are waking up to let's
say the meaning in Scripture or that
you're reaching out to the outside let's
say people that are that are agnostic or
atheist and then all of a sudden they
haven't seen the reference that you're
talking about like they don't they're
not seeing that underlying our
storytelling is the story of of Christ
basically which is which kind of keep
popping up no matter what we do even if
sometimes the moviemaker doesn't even do
it on purpose yeah I I think that I'm
getting quite a mixture of all sorts of
people I've gotten atheists that got on
there and says you know like for
instance my Shawshank Redemption video
you got on there and says I'm an
absolutely atheist and I think that
religion is the bane of society and but
I think you've absolutely nailed this
movie
and you did a fantastic job or something
that affects so you you can get a wide
array of people I think that there's
literalists and there's non to
literalists and I think that that that
that runs the gamut of people who are
religious and non-religious I think that
there's religious people who are very
literal and there's non-religious people
who are very literal and there's
religious people who are non literal
there's non-religious people who are are
non-literal I don't know that that it
seems to me that there's just a that's
an odd thing I mean people the
conversations that I've had with people
I see that Christians will often get
upset you know that can't be the case
you know even just in a movie because
they sings all things literal yeah nay
theist might say no I totally get what
you're talking about
hmm Iida there's an interesting story
kind of around my circles I did an
interview I did a movie interpretation
of the movie gravity yeah Quran and I
did it I did the Thomas went on
savannahrose on from the storyteller
storytellers channels I don't you've
heard this anyways yeah you don't have
grannies doing on the story because I
love the storytellers too and I was like
man you hooked up with them yeah I
pretty much I would say Thomas by now is
one of my partners like we we've been
doing several videos together on my
channel and he edits my videos and
everything and so he kind of took he had
some intuitions about Quran as well then
he took the stuff I did in gravity and
he made a video about this pattern in
Ron's movies where in every single one
of his movies someone will like go down
into water and almost die and then come
out right yeah and so until Quran and
invited both of us to the premiere for
his latest movies Roma and and Thomas
got to meet him cuz I couldn't go to the
premiere in New York I had to go to the
premiere in Montreal and so I I didn't
meet him he wasn't room in Montreal but
Thomas got to meet him and he started
talking to him and you know and and
Quran you about his videos and in my
videos as well and he asked him about
that about this pattern about this
baptism pattern that is in his movies
and Koren looked at him and said you
know what I never noticed
uh-huh it's like he in his every single
one of his movies he has this
but he himself had never noticed that he
was doing it just how powerful these
these story these stories are like how
underlying they are you know oh so let
me just get this straight so Sandra
Bullock character falls into the water
at the very end right yeah and crawls
out right and it stands up you know what
yeah Charles albumin stands up on the
ground he didn't see any symbolic
meaning in that he had never noticed
that he would do something similar to
that in every single one of his movie
that he had a had he had a kind of a
baptism resurrection or death
resurrection image that went into water
and came out in Rome and they have the
same story the lady in Roma goes into
the water and to save the the child and
then she brings them out and in this
then they have this like moment of
reconsider everybody kind of comes
together like in this almost communion
moment and you think my goodness like
seriously
and they never notice did you do that
it's a to me it's it's a it really is it
you didn't deny that he did that he
don't know he was like yeah yeah he
thought it was awesome that's why he
liked the videos the interpretation
videos so much because he's like oh
that's great that I but I just never
knew that I did that I think it's great
that now I seen this pattern in my my
movie maker but he just like I said he
just shows you just how how underlying
the story is ours you could you can use
them without even knowing that you're
using them it's like there it really is
like a reference in in our in our
existence that just basic tropes you
know I remember writing a song with a
friend of mine who was very young and we
ended up spending hours writing this
song and we kept seeing it and then we
we go why this sounds really familiar
and we pulled up another song and it was
the exact same song it was so much in
part of us we simply just started
regurgitating what we had already but we
already know and that so often happens I
mean artists are not just regurgitating
but they're creatively working I don't
know if you've seen the access of
awesome the show the access that's the
show but the group and they take the
four chords that are in every so yeah I
seen that yeah I see how many of
different songs and it's like every
everybody does it because we only have
so many chords to play right and there
are there really are just so many
patterns that you can actually tell the
story with
because like a story is basically that
it's made to you know it's that what it
did this is this idea of the U shape did
this u-shaped story this basic pattern I
remember when we were younger my brother
and I we would we would try to take the
dumbest like the dumbest pop songs like
and then we wouldn't we would show that
they had cosmic patterns in them like
Red Hot Chili Peppers song and and show
that they had like this this this this
cosmic image in it and and I and I I
don't think we were making it up at all
like it was just you need to pattern in
order to to create any coherent you know
unity and so he it's like okay here in
the story I can show you like your the
elements everything kind of follows this
pattern yeah so what are your plans for
your channel like what are you what are
you because I've for a while I think you
did you kind of slow down and I but I
saw you you you you seem to be picking
up pace again i I've been doing about
three a year I think that's what I mean
I'd like to do more I'd like to do it
faster but I really I'm kind of a
perfectionist that way and I feel like I
don't want to just I don't want to say
what other people have said simply I
have I like to say things that are new
and I'd like to get to the heart of
something so sometimes I'll be working
on something I'll find something new I'm
like I got to rework the whole thing
again so right now I'm working on a
rival and I've been working on a rival I
served with the three-part series on
memento arrival and signs okay I'm in a
right now I just did memento are you
gonna do science - yeah I've been
wanting to do sign because that's a
great bit okay so alright so we had a
little bit of a cut off here but I was
gonna just gonna ask Matthew about did
say he's gonna do the movie sign because
I've been thinking about making that
doing that movie as well I thought it is
very meaningful so I think the way I was
going to take it is I'm kind of doing
about interpretation meeting and the
problem of evil that's where it's headed
the question is is that in science the
reason I was I thought about doing size
not just signs of itself I think science
in itself is fairly straightforward but
yeah but how do we answer the problem of
evil and that's the question is how can
a loving God all loving all-powerful God
allow evil and suffering and you can ask
me the question there
answer the question but a answer is it
answers it in a narrative format and if
you go back to amendment o is the
question of interpretation of meaning
momento fragments meaning ya
by other than the person be a short-term
memory loss and it works everything
backwards and it comes from that that's
that phrase or it works with that idea
from
søren kierkegaard that says that life
can only be understood looking backwards
but it must live forwards and if you
take those two ideas together it means
that temporal life can never be
understood as because we don't have the
complete context yet let's go back and
going back and yeah that's what signs oh
you're right you're totally right that's
what science does it's like nothing
makes sense until the final moment and
then you know absolutely and and when
you get to the idea of science it's the
idea for most atheists and Christians
you have the idea we all know that evil
and suffering exists right we look at
the world and that's what we know it's
very plain that that should have
happened that's the bad try there was
nothing that child did there was no
moral order at least a parent more order
in what took place and that child
apparently from what we see will never
get anything back and receive anything
good from that event yeah and so people
say that that can't be I think I has a
thing out there about how dare you God
if I ever met God how dare you you're
evil
so Christians and atheists both look at
that
data but they come to very different
conclusions so that the Atheist looks at
that and says and this is just like
signs if you watched halfway through
signs and you got halfway to signs you
would say well God isn't good I mean it
couldn't be because you know all this
stuff happens his wife dies his daughter
you know has problems water you know I
mean these aliens are coming and his
brother didn't make anything of his life
you know that his life is a wreck I'm
living with his brother and working at a
gas station when he could be playing
baseball but that happened so you get to
the center point and that's in essence
in our lives we get to the center point
of our lives and we looked at the past
and we see these bad things that happen
and we have to make a determination what
does our future hold
yeah I love you say the centerboard
you making a Dante references
consciously or not happen at the middle
of my life that's when he anyway sorry
he's lost in a wood yeah yeah first
canto so so we the idea so we're making
a determination and it's a faith
determination because neither the
atheist nor the Christian knows what's
going to happen in the fracture yeah the
atheist prejudges the future based upon
the knowledge of the past and their
knowledge of the past is bad things have
happened therefore the future can that
will only be as its as it was in the
past there because we see that there was
no more order in the past there was no
God there was nothing there therefore
the future will be exactly like that to
the Christian comes to it and looks to
the past and says I know that evil
exists but I also know that pain and
suffering can lead to a good result so
for instance my father disciplined me
and I became a better person as a result
you know my I tell the story of my
daughter when she was younger she had a
of the flu and they had to I had to hold
her arm down this is when she's like
less than 1 years old and they had to
put an injector with some medication and
she looked at me and terror as they put
a needle and what are you doing to me
daddy yeah she has no idea what I'm
doing because I'm doing it for her good
she has no idea but she looks at me like
I'm evil but I had to do it in order to
to not save her life but I mean in terms
of making her feel better but the point
is is that Krishna's looked at that and
they say well if that's true of the past
if good and evil and suffering could
happen we can look at the future and say
well that could be true of the future
now it's nor the Christian know with
certainty what will happen in future but
the Christian stands in faith just as
the eight he stands in faith and says I
believe in a future that will be like
that and that's and that's part of the
Herman circle because we don't have the
complete story yet the story isn't
finished yet we haven't seen it or
written but what we have is a promise I
hope written in the Bible but we haven't
seen it with certainty yet and therefore
we come as you said with the you know
symbolizing our lives with that
expectation in that hope writing that
story into the the things we do in our
lives how we build our buildings how we
and we go
about our actions and I think that's the
answer the answer the problem of evil is
is that it could be and it's a matter of
faith and in fact is is that by faith by
living in faith we actually do in some
sense bring about the future that we
hope for and such as fate in the story
that's right and some say that that's an
existential idea is that we we become
who we want to be we make the future we
want it to be as it we want it to be and
so by believing in God by believing in
Jesus we are in some sense participating
with God and bringing about the future
that yes yeah I agree I agree and I
think that there's also in our very
perception of the patterns like I said
before that we also see a hint of what
you're talking about because we can see
that for the a world to exist the
accidental and the arbitrary actually
have to come together into a meaningful
pattern or else the world doesn't exist
or else it's just it's just it's just
dust and so because I see that in and
once we understand what you perceive
that's how logos operates in the world
then we we can understand it we can also
see that yes okay so it means that the
big story will also have to have that
element where things are going to have
to come together in the big in a bigger
story than the one I can even perceive
because I see it at every level of
reality and so even the one that I can't
that I'm participating in let's say that
I'm a part of and looking trying to see
how it's all going to coalesce that it
that it should follow the same pattern
you know because that's just how that's
how the world exists it's like there's
no other way for the world to exist that
goes back to art and in terms of how we
interpret the medium of our own lives we
have this idea that I can make meaning
for my life and my life is meaningful
because I declare it to be meaningful
you know atheists will say my life is
meaningful without God God doesn't make
anything meaningful in my life can be
meaningful and ceteris but the problem
is with that is that in terms of the
hermitage circle is that meaning is is
bound up in context and that it's bound
up by the people who understand the
meaning so so a language is meaningful
because there are people who speak the
language right so so I understand what
you're saying
because we both speak English and and so
on and so forth but if you get outside
the boundaries of what English is you
you you know English is no longer in
some sense meaningful now we can agree
to be meaningful but as you extrapolate
out meaning is only found in humanity in
humans the meaning and what happens is
is that as you extrapolate further and
further out into the context of the
universe if there is no god if mind is
not the fundamental aspect of the world
yeah
then there is no meaning because
ultimately all of this is going to be
gone you know they're willed enough that
nothing holds it together and if that's
the Atheist perspective and I think that
you know so people say well I can make
meaning for my life well I mean in some
sense you can't because in terms of the
macro you might think you're creating
meaning meaning for the moment there
really there's nothing that is
ultimately meaningful yeah Oh
meaningless but I think I think that
we're at a good time in terms of a lot
of philosophers and a lot of science is
not a lot but at least a good few even
atheists or even agnostics are starting
to notice the problem of consciousness
and the problem of of meaning and qualia
and and the notion that things have
qualities in the world and are realizing
that we have a problem like we have a
problem because like you said you know
meaning it seems to be an elementary
constant constituent of the reality
without it we don't have anything we
just have quantum flux like we just have
this field of you know of nothingness
and so so it's a good time I think it's
a good time for people who understand
Christianity in a in an ontological way
that we understand that what we're
talking about is not just these
arbitrary stories we're talking about
how reality actually exists and how we
can participate in that existence I
think I think it's an interesting time I
don't know if you you know if you ever
heard of Sam axe was the confessor and
some of these fathers like saying rigor
of me sensei max is the confessor I've
heard of him I haven't read you might
enjoy some accidents cuz he really I
think he gives us the key today in terms
of how logos exists in the world and how
as human beings we are you know the
image of God in the world and we we
actually gather all of phenomena into
ourselves
and then we kind of offer it up to God
and we become also the receptacle of
that grace by which the world kind of
holds together and so it's like human
being and the Incarnation being the
summit of that like the ultimate version
of that is this this place where all the
meaning kind of comes together and it
seems to to be a manner of speaking
which people can understand today which
people who are not Christian not don't
even believe in God can kind of say okay
all right I know what you're talking
about at least you're not just talking
about some here to go on the sky who
sends like me you're actually talking
about reality no I met you it I I really
enjoyed this conversation I I definitely
had a lot of fun I would suggest there's
a lot of people that you should talk to
do you know have you heard of Paul van
der clay I've heard of him but never met
he would love I think he would like to
talk to you you probably really enjoy
talking to him there's a few other
people as well and we could maybe we
could also organize another talk at some
point absolutely
absolutely very much enjoyed it yeah it
was great to find someone who is engaged
and interested in this stuff as like I
said my my world is not hey I would look
for people who are really engaged in
this stuff and that's kind of
interesting but that's what's great
about the online space that's the one
one of the positive things about the
online space I always joke with people
why not joking I'm actually serious when
I tell people that before I started
making these youtube videos I never
talked about symbolism with anybody yeah
I don't talk about that stuff because
it's not it only matters this certain
very small amount of strangely minded
people who kind of see these patterns
but for most people you know if you're
living a good life you believe in God
you pray you go to church I know you you
don't need you don't even need this like
you're fine you can keep doing your
thing but for some people they because
they have this intuition it's it's
helpful for them to to see through the
veils you could say absolutely
absolutely and so all the best with your
channel and we'll all be looking forward
to seeing more content and oh yeah
hopefully we'll talk soon all right see
you later all right
if you enjoy the symbolic world content
there's a lot of things you can do to
help us out if you're not subscribe
please do go ahead and share this to all
your friends
you can get involved in the discussion
we have a Facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com